نمط الحياة البيئي وتاريخ عائلتك،
بعض العوامل التي يمكن أن
تلعب دوراً في تشخيص السرطان، ومعرفة
خطر إصابتك بالمرض يمكن أن
ينقذ حياتك، ونحن قادرون على التوصية
بأنواع مبكرة أو أكثر تكراراً من
الفحوصات حتى نتمكن من اكتشاف هذه
السرطانات في وقت مبكر  أو ربما حتى منعهم،
تقول بريانا ميتشل، مستشارة الوراثة في Mayo Clinic، إن هذا الاختبار يمكن أن
يحدد خطر الإصابة بأنواع عديدة من السرطان،
في حين أن وجود جين ضار محتمل
لا يضمن إصابتك بالمرض، كما
تقول، يمكن للاختبار عادةً تحديد
نطاق الخطر في الخطوة الأولى.  هو الحصول على
موعد مع مستشار وراثي،
حيث نراجع
تاريخ عائلتك، ونسألك عن تلك التفاصيل حول تلك
السرطانات، وتعرف كم كان عمر شخص ما
عندما أصيب به، وما هي أنواع السرطانات
ونقوم بنوع من التقييم والتقييم
لمعرفة ما إذا كان  نحن نفي بالمعايير،
ولن ينظر المستشار إلى
تاريخ السرطان الشخصي والعائلي فحسب، بل إلى
النسب أو وجود خلايا غير طبيعية
إذا كنت مؤهلاً، ويتم إجراء الاختبار
إما عن طريق اختبار الدم الذي يتم سحبه محليًا
أو من خلال مجموعة اللعاب في المنزل حتى لو
لم تكن كذلك  تلبية المعايير، لا يزال بإمكانك
إجراء الاختبار لمعظم المرضى بغض النظر عما
إذا كان التأمين الخاص بهم يغطي
اختباراتهم أم لا، وعادةً ما يكونون قادرين على دفع
أقل من 500 دولار مقابل هذا النوع من الاختبارات
للدقيقة الصحية، أنا آندي جايثر